could you be a vegetarian oh easily yeah
really yeah I think so for how long you
say this now I just love the way you're
saying this like it's such a brave thing
like I could do it I can live on edge
mean my vegetarians all around the world
are just like this [__] I will I
I will fully admit I could never listen
the two things I care about most beer
and coffee vegan
friendly I'm good to go also I've had
vegan food specifically in like in
California because their vegan game is
off the charts to be fair it's gotten
way way better it is insane I I'm sure
it's some of the foods are terrible for
you but their vegan level is through the
roof they [__] that tastes way better
than anything I could ever get totally
normally just vegan I'm like how are you
doing this what are you putting in this
food the the hard Choice has never been
giving up like okay going like go going
like a vegetarian life or something like
that to me it's always like the biggest
factor out of anything in terms of a
choice is is convenience yeah you know
it's it's like sometimes all right it's
sometimes you just go out for a bender
and it's like 1:00 and you're like do I
really want to be thinking about like oh
is this am I eating something vegan or
vegetarian right now or do I just order
[__] mackys cuz I'm like [__] Dr I
think you just adapt you pretty I'm
going to order macis after this
recording I'm already not you just get
really used to just thinking about that
kind of stuff and it's just a different
and you just get very I I I speak to
vegetarians and some
vegans I don't like to associate with
them normally but uh when I do associate
with them it's just easy i i i as
especially in like America America it's
very easy in Japan it's obviously a lot
harder it's getting a lot easier though
for sure yeah I mean there's a as a
vegan chain I think there's one in shuku
and uh oh dude I mean like you you you
you think like 5 10 years ago in Japan
like the concept of veganism didn't even
exist here this is one place where I
think one of my favorite pastures in
Japan is gluten and vegan M and it it
should God TI you I don't know how they
do it what are they putting in there as
in gluten and gluten free and gluten
glutenfree and vegan free past uh and
vegan uh vegan free no no vegans
allowed any vegans it is like my
honestly like top three PES for me in
Japan it's so [__] good really yeah
and they do a vegan tiramisu it's God TI
like I don't know how they're doing this
probably a lot of sugar and a lot of fat
but still very good well it makes you
think how much of the culinary world is
based on like very few things you can
add a lot of things to make stuff tasty
no no no no like we we've like okay
we've gotten so used to like imagine
Western the Western culinary world yeah
if cows didn't
[Music]
exist like we're [__] we're [__]
yeah like cows are literally like Zeus
holding up a wall right now yeah yeah
yeah like what happens if we don't have
cow and [__] wheat we're [__] you
know like like like so much of it is
based on things that few animals can
provide yeah go for it if the impossible
Burgers the no meat Burgers taste as
good as normal beef burgers will you
will you just be like yeah I'm not going
to eat any more beef I don't really care
yeah yeah me neither well actually I cuz
I stopped uh Burger King in Japan had a
plant-based burger and I thought it
tastes way better than their actual
Burgers yeah and they stopped doing it
I'm like why like like well your first
problem is eating Burger King so well
sometimes I want like the burger and I
didn't want to get McDonald's and I used
to go to Burger King cuz I had the
plant-based one it was so [__] good
[__] rid of it to me the Big Choice
isn't going like vegan or like meat
place plant P all this [__] just give me
[__] that tastes good that's that's all
I really care about you know if if it
tastes good I'm not really going to Care
I've had I've had plenty of like vegan
dishes at like restaurants and like
cafes and stuff where I'm like okay yeah
this is really [__] good like it's
absolutely amazing but I've also had
vegan you know dishes in some
restaurants and cafes where I'm like
it's kind of ass not going to lie it's
it's it's a lot of the times cuz I've
had like I remember my first time trying
vegan cheese and it's very similar to
trying non-alcoholic beer where it's
just like you know it's it's like it
looks like cheese yeah I know this is
like you're vegan right you can't have
cheats right but you have that cheese
itch maybe you know what it tasted like
it's going to scratch that itch a little
bit and I guess but like I I think I
think like ultimately having these
options is never a Bad
Thing [__] garbage like the single
slic cheese can barely be considered
cheese but some people like it uh and
they love it on Burgers don't know why
it tastes good I don't know how they
figured it out but it does yeah I mean
like this isn't me trashing like
everyone who makes the choice who want
to go vegan because there are like
plenty of reasons to want to go vegan I
mean ultimately healthier probably than
me
prob at at the end of the day
is I think the big reason a lot of
people don't is not because of an
environmental choice or any ethical
Choice people like if it's convenient
and if you know it's not the mentality
is now that a lot of vegan stuff is done
as a replacement to things people
already used to as as opposed to just
hey this stuff tastes good by itself
like in in terms of like coming into to
it with like an open mind you know and I
think I think that's the biggest image
thing that these kinds
of uh different diets have right now
which is to convince people over you
need to convince them to replace what
they have in their diet now and kind of
use a substitute you know uh whereas for
me I would be very happy to be vegan or
vegetarian if I just had really good
tasting food and I just didn't need to
think about if
if I had enough good tasting food that
wasn't meat-based I wouldn't miss the
burgers you know yeah cuz I I I would
have enough things in my diet you know I
like fish a lot though fish is great
fish is great you know we're we're not
even remotely close to getting like fish
textures replicated like bur because
they've been focusing so much on meat
true I I taste so much to replicate meat
you know yeah but I I think also it
makes sense to try and replicate like
beef specifically cuz how much water and
how much uh methane cows release [__] so
it makes sense did you see that video of
like the the there was like this vegan
shift that tried to make like uh like
steak but you like but just frying a
watermelon yeah did this [__] and she
was like yeah this uh I
tried it doesn't taste like beef dude
some fish when you cook them right
tastes like steaks totally you ever had
swordfish yeah it tastes so good you had
uh tuna as well some some tuna some tuna
steaks and like you know like salmon
steak and stuff like that what do you
mean no some tuna steaks can taste like
steak some tuna steaks can taste like
like meat really good steaks yeah I
haven't had it I I I like you should
stop no no tuna
it's they taste like they taste a bit
tougher but to say they taste like an
actual beef steak tougher tougher what
the no no no no what the [__] as in like
top as as if like okay as in t as in
like you know fish are normally like
very like flaky and like they're they're
normally very flaky crumbly okay that
was what I was looking for like tuna
does not always have that consistency I
like that I like that but to say that it
tastes like a beef Ste you can cook a
tuna to tastes as good as a steak and
like it can have the the tech the
texture and like profile of a
steak you can do it you can do it I
disagree I'll take you to a place it's
it's I know a guy it might I know a
place know I got a guy the the one thing
the one thing is that it's just never
okay one thing taste aside it's just
never as chewy as like a steak that's
that's that's one thing I've never seen
like replicated in the tuna here hate
that part the che of hate the chewy part
of steak oh it's [__] awesome no no
no I want my food to be like a tire yeah
I want to feel like I'm eating a rubber
boot the per the perfect steak is when
you like you you chew into a bit and
then the like moisture just bursts
out you like my least favorite part of
like the the juiciness and the are you
kidding me what the [__] that is my
least fa that's the least favorite part
of this I'm sorry I'm [__] spinning
cuz I'm getting like so you're talking
to someone who said steak is mid all
right like you can't convince me guys
the reason why wag you steak is the most
top tier steak is because of the
juiciness and the fat that comes out of
it when it isn't chewy it's not chewy
wagu is not chewy okay Wag the good
thing about the thing that justs wag you
apart from regular steak is the fact
that it's not chewy and melts melts on
your mouth it's not a good piece of fish
no no every bite every bite you take you
it it doesn't even feel like a bike
because it's so tender right yeah
because it's so tender that's that's the
whole point of it every where Che saying
you want chewy I want chewi oh chewiness
okay when I said chewiness it means like
with like with a tuna it just feels like
it doesn't have that same kind of like
not toughness but like it's uh what's
what's the vitual word I just use
tenderness to it I don't know like it it
it feel it feels like it just falls
apart no I've had some tuna that is
tenderous f you can have some really
like meaty boys really good Stak like
some thick pieces of tuna like woo you
just get a lot of mercury and also the
thing I just talked about which is that
kind of like juiciness and you get that
I'll take it to your place no no no I
know okay here they did the here thing
here the thing like cuz like that fatty
tuna does exist uh but we're talking
regular lean tuna okay lean tuna like
that has like a little bit more
toughness to it but it's nowhere near
the consistency of the St even even a
very tender steak absolutely no way
we're all going we're all going and I'm
take there we're all going to take a
bite of this it's amazing easy it's it
is it's like $40 for this bloody thing
so good no no I'm not okay here's the
thing I [__] love tuna steaks tuna
steaks are great that's not one I'm
arguing here I'm I'm arguing like that
you are saying that you've had tuna that
tastes like steak which is which I have
I have I have no I'm taking I'm I taking
you there I'm shattering your world viw
get back when I get back from Vegas if I
have any money left we every time I've
had something that's a tuna steak I'm
like this is [__] amazing is it like
is it an actual steak no what if we just
put it in front of you without you
knowing it was tuna oh that this would
be so [__] easy this would be so easy
the the the drawer of the the tuna steak
is that when you bite into it like the
crust is similar of that to a steak CU
they can cook it that way they get
really crispy and when you get on the
inside it's really soft cuz it's tun
that's that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying it's really really soft
you don't feel like the muscle fibers or
anything I don't want to feel the muscle
fibers that's the what you get with Ste
I don't
like that's why I don't like steak I
hate the muscle fibers that is the worst
part of the when I when I bite down to
like I'm I'm doing like a [__] Sait
force of like and and and I can't
[__] sep at this meat I'm like Christ
a l i hate that part of the state
literally the worst part of the state
thank you very much no no no that's how
you know that it's a [__] steak okay
I don't I know it's a steak I see it
give me a good steak how' you like your
steak Joey how' you like your steak
medium rare medium rare okay you get
like a small like the best Stakes are is
when that's like a good balance
obviously you're you're you're making it
sound like a steak is [__] a blue
steak you know where you're just like
yeah I'm [__] ra animal okay no like
a good medium rare State you you get a
little bit of that you get a little bit
of like bounce back with like the chewi
and the fat and everything that comes
out and then it just goes down good tuna
steak is is just way too soft you don't
get that same resistance tuna steak is a
steak that's cut out all the [__]
it's clearly not meat okay that's that's
that's what I'm saying that's what I'm
saying no man you got to take him to
this CH
St we're about to lose right
here
yeah no you're wrong [__] s [__] sake I
need another beer